thank you
foreign
okay
foreign
foreign
foreign
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilet but shakes
[Music]
while looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elephants and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
what on Earth is going on with Trump and
toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
Obama
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation a big massive dumps
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude he is gone ladies and
gentlemen Alex Jones is now very very
upset with me look at that that is a
freaking prefer right there he thinks
he's smarter than you think he's better
than you and he's gonna beat you Pac-Man
never talked to the new world war
because Pac-Man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true I'm not a knight
at the round that that actually is
accurate that dude is
[Music]
[Music]
that is a freaking prep director
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's gonna
beat you
well it's a very special day because we
have today returning to the program Mike
Lindell CEO and inventor of my pillow
what
what would you like me to say David
[Music]
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
what's so hard to understand
they can pull these names it's just like
every state every state has people that
voted that don't live in the state hold
it David you're doing the population of
Wisconsin I have a moral compass who
million you can get them I did I got
requests on to everything these are
right on the voter rolls David you're
not listening you're not
[Music]
get rid of my espresso machine the
voting machine David everything that can
be packed you got you know credit cards
companies can hack businesses act gas
companies act who did this attack who
did this Cyber attack that's all I'm
about we can't have computers running
our election Mike you've mentioned so
much let me just make one comment here
nope nope nope melt them down and turn
them into prison bars
[Music]
when you have a computer you can change
one number you can do anything you hack
in and you can expect Millions where if
you had to do the same thing with paper
you'd have to have a hold of all of
people you asked me the dumb question
about getting rid of machines if you
want to be a humorous interview get rid
of my espresso machine
[Applause]
[Music]
you should have one of my pillows too we
are gonna take a moment to recover here
from the extremely high level of energy
I could talk to you all day about this
foreign
[Music]
fingers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified
be affected
don't want me to me
this highway robbery is what you doing
[Music]
I'm worried about my espresso machine
it's not a joke I'm worried about my
Lane
[Music]
who did this attack who did this Cyber
attack so you have you know the good
Geeks and they patch it up and they fix
it and they put up better protection
virus protection but here's what my
attorney said she said
um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through on
the lid to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
Madison you're not getting my phone I
said arrest me I've done nothing mommy
said no we're not gonna arrest you I
sure you can do anything you have here
and you can do it you can do okay
um get rid of the machine I've tried for
getting rid of the machine I'm worried
about my pillow no no truth that's the
worst thing for you because your
cervical nerves in your neck I will send
you some pillows I'm worried about my
legs
Okay Melt them down and turn them into
prison bars
all right thanks Mike Take Care thank
you
wow I am exhausted from that
introduction what a high energy and high
profile event with everybody saying
hello diamond and silk uh Mike pillow
and everybody I am wearing my glasses
anticipating a very very late night I
can't be messing around with contact
lenses it just would not be allowed I
would have to end the stream prematurely
and nobody wants that we are now
entering ladies and gentlemen for the
few thousand of you that are here right
at the top of the stream today we're
entering a critical
an absolutely critical a critical or an
absolutely critical let's be precise on
the grammar there
four really five day period five day
period of politics in America
which will culminate hopefully with
something other than the end of
democracy as we know it
that's my hope now if you came to me
tears the whole thing calling me sir
and said do I prefer democracy
or slightly lower gas prices
I choose democracy
but I drive an electric car
if you go to the magats and say which do
you prefer
I think we know the answer
I think we know the answer so this is
really an incredibly critical moment in
American elections and you all know that
I don't blow smoke I don't smoke right
but I'm certainly not blowing it
anywhere up anywhere in out or anything
around okay
if these midterm elections were not
particularly important
if these were like
you know the 2014 midterms
tea party was already in Decline it
wasn't like 2010.
Obama had just been re-elected two years
prior Obama
I wouldn't be saying to you these are
absolutely critical midterm elections I
just have no interest in hyperbole here
which is like the Super Bowl it's
hyperbole
um but these I believe are the most
important and potentially consequential
and potentially disastrous I'm sorry to
say my friends uh midterm elections that
I have covered since I've started the
show
and we all know why we are on the
precipice
of
a slew of absolute anti-democracy
lunatics being elected
what are we even watching here by the
way
is it oh whoops no that is uh uh okay
they're back to the Trump rally soon
um Carrie Lake
Doug mastriano
Herschel Walker
Adam lack salt the Republican in Oregon
whose name I forget Tudor Dixon
Kevin's tit in Oklahoma up for
reelection
these are people who will just try to
steal electoral votes in 2024.
it is hard to imagine higher Stakes
and so
we're going to be here
I'm going to talk about polling in a
moment
I hope every single one of you who is an
American citizen in 18 years of age is
going to vote once which is
the only amount of times anybody votes
right
um because this is so absolutely
critical now let me say a word about
polling after reading the Super Chat did
I receive the pillows from Mike pillow
yet no Mike pillow promised to send me
pillows so I could try them never did he
said his assistant would reach out to me
and just didn't never heard from anybody
uh so unfortunately I'm not gonna be
able to try him nor the bed sheets I'm
not going to be able to try anything
here's the deal with the polling okay
many of you uh wrote To Me pointing out
look David
these numbers now where Republicans are
now favored to win the Senate
these numbers where Democrats are down
to only a 15 chance of winning in the
house these numbers wherein Herschel
Walker is now leading Rafael Warnock or
these numbers wherein uh Kemp is now
leading Stacy Abrams by eight these are
trash polls like just dumps massive
dumps stuff you would get rid of
sanitize start fresh okay bleach it
inject bleach these are worth nothing
here's where I am on this we have five
days we have five days left until this
election
if you believe that the polls are
terrible and Democrats are probably
leading a lot of these races
we're not going to take a chance you
take your one vote and you vote
if you believe that Republicans really
are on the upswing as the polls suggest
then we go out and we use our one vote
and we vote right it's like a this is
like the prisoner's dilemma okay the
great mathematician John Nash prisoners
dilemma the the scenario is I don't know
how many do people know about prisoners
dilemma
have I been muted this entire time am I
not even live
no I'm kidding people know about
prisoners dilemma prisoner's dilemma is
this scenario wherein it's it's a game
theory thing
um you and your friend uh committed a
crime together you're equally culpable
of the crime police find you they bring
you in you don't know to ask for a
lawyer you don't know to shut the you
know up and not say a damn word they
separate you
and they say listen
um your friend in the other room
he's gonna confess okay
if you both confess
um you guys are going to prison for some
number of years and if you both just
keep your mouth shut you're still gonna
go to prison but it's gonna be a smaller
number of years but if your friend
doesn't confess and you tell us the
truth
uh or what man I don't even remember you
know what
it's too late for this crap the point is
no matter what your friend is going to
do you always have a preferred action
that is better for you okay I forget
what it is it's been it's been
18 years I don't know how long it's been
since I took Game Theory Okay I uh I was
on the right track I know I I just
forgot guys the point here is it's a
prisoner's dilemma we have a Nash
equilibrium we have a burrito optimal a
choice if you think Republicans are
winning you go and you vote if you think
Democrats are winning you go and you
vote because if you need to be one of
the Democrats in the polls that say
you're winning
you just vote guys
Dear God
forget the polls let's look at the polls
now okay no I'm kidding you all
understand what I'm saying at this point
it's not even worth spending much time
it's abundantly clear that the momentum
has shifted in the direction of
Republicans just look at this right look
at this the the momentum has gone for
republicans
are they really ahead we just don't know
so they've got the momentum
we're gonna go and vote and that's it
okay guys that's it fine
um let me get this uh foreign
I want to get this
properly set up just so it'll look right
I just want to make sure that we're all
good here whoa I don't need to move that
let's just see here uh okay we got that
I just don't want my audience to even
miss a single Pixel oh it looks like
we're actually good
yeah yeah we're good all right so we'll
tuck that there and then dip this under
and maybe Center it there we go okay
good we're all very good let's make sure
we have audio show from Texas okay there
we go all right welcome everybody I am
so glad to have you here we have only a
few days left until the midterm
elections I need to tell you this right
now we have a bunch of potential streams
planned for the next five days including
live coverage on Election night for
which I hope you will join me you might
be looking above my head and saying
David is that a typo is the goal a
thousand website members and twitch
subscribers that can't possibly be right
it is now we're going to carry that
through to election day the goal is
between now and election day there's
going to be many streams and the better
they go the more streams there will be
we've got Trump rallies I might do an
Obama fetterman rally which would be
amazing
um there's so many rallies over the next
few days and we may be doing a ton of
them we're going to carry wherever we
get this through all the way to Tuesday
if we get to a thousand early I mean I
don't know that's gonna happen if we get
to a thousand early we'll go 2 000 we're
trying to set a new record here we are
here I cannot believe this but as s Prez
to give us an auspicious start just
dumped in a hundred twitch subscriptions
already and we are off and running I
also want to say thanks to mechanically
reclaimed meet Shannon Lee flea girl
Nikki
Cortina Jeremy Ranch sorry Jeremy Ranch
Sarah is cool deeper shades of house
dirt nap and Billy Carpenter as well as
ZZ gifting five that's 13 a hundred plus
thirteen three plus zero nothing to
carry one plus zero nothing to carry
that puts us at a hundred and thirteen
and very importantly thank you to Jason
sickmeyer for signing up on my website
joinpakman.com folks we're at 114
memberships and we are only just
starting here
yeah okay thank you geez Donald's
getting uh getting very excited let's
continue let's continue because we have
so many things to look at here
earlier in this event actually let's
just refresh and get the latest clips of
the things that have been going on
um
Herschel Walker made a statement should
we just listen to it just to be thorough
Walker how'd that speech go down in the
state of Georgia
well that speech didn't go down that
well at all because the biggest threat
to the to the democracy is Joe Biden
being in the White House the biggest
threat and the democracy is with Senator
why not and Joe Biden with this High
inflation and that's a threat to the
Democracy right there the biggest threat
to Demarcus is hard to argue with that
because I don't understand what the hell
he's saying the crime that they've let
come on the streets and all this has
happened in less than two years that
they've been in been in at the White
House
I really can't argue against that
because I would need to understand it to
argue against it Chuck Grassley is
defiantly committing to continue his
investigation of Hunter Biden I've got
several things to say today but one
thing that that I want to start out with
so you can have confidence in me if I'm
re-elected yes I'm not going to give up
on trying to get political bias out of
the FBI
the Paramount issue for America at this
point in time
and I'm not going to give up on my
investigation of Hunter Biden
people are insane he is not going to
give that I didn't know he was
investigating Hunter Biden uh but he's
certainly not going to stop anytime soon
that's for um that's absolutely for sure
[Music]
Chuck Grassley is going to be learning
HTML just so he can personally inspect
the browser history of uh of Hunter
Biden
um what else do we have from this event
think I had to oh Marjorie Trader green
was there where Americans are robbed
raped kidnapped carjacked and murdered
but only the only crime victim you hear
about from Democrats in the media is
Paul Pelosi yeah
[Music]
Paul Pelosi was brutally attacked by a
drugged out illegal alien that should
have been deported and Paul Pelosi
should have been a gun owner and shot
his attacker right because Bill Gates
wants you to eat his fake meat that
grows in a peach tree dish gazpacho
police yeah they probably also want to
know when you go to the bathroom and if
your bowel movements are are on time
yes Marjorie Taylor green I'm really
getting a lot of use out of those I have
to tell you these people are sick these
people are very very sick and uh they
they are the violent ones you know
that's the reality
um they encourage the violence they say
knock them knock them around I'll pay
for your legal fees and and all of it it
is painful to watch it's more painful to
watch quite frankly than the fetterman
debate which I admitted was painful to
watch I felt really bad for what was
going on super chats coming in even if
you decide even if you vote and lose at
least vote
says since who don't allow uh the the
don't allow the to claim a mandate vote
yes absolutely sin Tzu tell Merrick we
have plenty of jail space
David sir can we please get a trump
audio glitch yeah uh hold on let's see
do I have that
Trump is this it further scream that his
days are numbers
yeah uh very very serious audio issues
taking place there and hoping to see
some tonight hello David loved seeing
you on Dr Rashad hope your appearances
together won't be too sporadic yes I was
on with Dr Rashad Ritchie part of I
believe the tyt network pleasure to be
on I talked about anti-semitism
um
not anti-semantics as a lot of people
misunderstand it had nothing to do with
syntax nor semantics nor grammar of any
kind the conversation I can't thank
enough the following people Johnny
manogue Robert Gonzalez Timothy O'Hearn
and Bryant Bryant Brian Brian
St Germain getting memberships on my
website I also want to say thanks to
Bureau Doug B Kimberly gifting five on
Twitch zalor Avon the dragon clown
Badness
Jay frick
DJ Kento gifted five and got one for
himself
that is 16 plus 118. man that's got to
be like a thousand right no 16 plus 118
is 134. we are running this through to
election day it is essentially daily
streams from here on out with your
support
it's great to have every single one of
you here
um this is just the first of many Trump
uh rallies Kerry Lake Obama fetterman we
just have a lot of really important
streams and this is it folks I mean
listen uh Joe Biden gave a speech last
night defending democracy
this is where we are
we are hey um
maybe we should like keep a democratic
system rather than becoming a dystopian
authoritarian dictatorial type country I
don't know
but maybe our gas prices would be higher
if that was the case we've got to look
into that and figure out which one we
want
that's where mag at is right now
it's absolutely vile
absolutely vile a couple other things to
look at here
uh let me just refresh and see what our
friend Ron filipkowski has for us from
the rally
um you may not have much
uh
not too much what did Junior say like
isn't that what everyone knew like from
day one now I understand
this was always an obvious conclusion
you're telling me it came from a wet
Market you know and all the stuff to
make them stronger and all of these
things oh I I can even though he's
making no sense I can tell he's talking
about covid well it never no way at
least from it it didn't leak from the
lab that does nothing but play with
these viruses it came from a bat that
someone was eating
to hurt Donald Trump to hurt
conservatives and to bolster and boost
the liberal nonsense agenda so
remember be skeptical of everything
these clowns tell you because they've
been lying to you from day one and they
think you're stupid
I don't know that there are enough drugs
in the entire city of West Palm Beach
Florida to uh make Don Jr sound coherent
I I it's just very very hard to imagine
that
um I'm going to skip that other Don Jr
one
um here is Marjorie Trader green singing
the Praises of Melania and Mrs Trump
accomplished so many great things she
was in the White House who's this new
host on right side broadcasting by the
way replacing Trump's lawyer she put
doing in the residence she fixed
she completely ignored there's it was a
real American Tragedy that the Rose
Garden was bad and then Melania fixed it
and actually she destroyed it she made
it look horrible problem among problem
there and it was ignored for years and
she went in intact I just think she was
the most wonderful first lady and she
doesn't get enough credit for that she
she has remained quiet she has taken all
of the attacks on her husband and her
family she's taking it with Grace
um and she she really deserves that
credit she's also I mean speaks how many
languages four yeah six oh on six six
six languages that's incredible um but
all we ever hear about is you know
Democrat first ladies she was a
supermodel beautiful fashion just such a
beautiful person yeah I mean guys why
doesn't Melania get more credit for her
fashion
you never hear about that yeah you go to
the bathroom are you sleeping there on
the concrete like walk us through how a
front row Joe survives out on these
locations for they're interviewing guys
who go to Trump rallies a lot a day's on
end we sleep in our cars or I even have
a cot tent that's set up and sleep in uh
I take my showers at Planet Fitness I
got a membership just to take shots
these are American Heroes ladies and
Gentlemen by the way the world sees this
and they go
why don't you guys have like better
mental health treatment in the country
so that's smart that's smart so for ten
dollars a month you can get a shower
anywhere in America no in order to go to
any Planet Fitness it's 25 a month 10
would only be for your local gym you
have to get the black car to 22.99 a
month there you go all right well at
least the guy's telling the truth about
that man we are really screwed as a
country really really screwed as a
country it's uh it's it's really bad
really bad how soon people forget the
investigation of Chelsea Clinton's Palm
Pilot in 1997 well said Daniel
thanks to a near benbak Chi nasty
questions Mrs rise Badger and
multi-beast for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 139 also
huge thank you to Wesley Taylor for
gifting three subscriptions no four
subscriptions on my website okay listen
if you want a free membership on my
website do not email me do not post
anything in chat do not leave a
voicemail do not send a telegram do not
send smoke signals do not sell a note
send a notarized letter if you want a
free membership
fill out the form at davidpackman.com
free membership that's all you have to
do
that's it they're genuinely free as
people gift memberships I will give them
away
do not email do not call do not tweet do
not truth
no
davidpackman.com free membership that's
all you need to do and we will give them
out in the order that people request
them let's listen to a voicemail or two
um
let's take a look
hey David
[Music]
the other day there happens to be a wife
of a veteran and she keeps bringing up
100 by 100 by 100 Biden yeah and I go
okay and she goes he smokes crack and
sends butt pictures and I'm like all
right I know about the crack I said but
what about the butt pictures she goes he
sends book pictures online and I'm like
is that any different than the first
lady posing naked when she was 25 for
Max magazine and she said that never
happened and I'm like get out of your
bubble and you'll find it yeah I can't
find pictures of Butt Bows or Hunters
but but I could find pictures of Melania
posing naked and she said Hunter Biden
belongs in the hole next to his brother
oh oh my God
these people are disgusting and that
died serving our country
they're despicable people man yeah very
much so very much so
man
hi David quick question
um you were going over daylight saving
time a few days ago in the bonus show
and I just wanted to know what you
thought about oh the bonus show where
you want to make money but everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad
um
my thinking is
you know whether we set the hour back or
not like this the Earth is still further
away from the Sun like the days are
going to be short shorter regardless so
I'm wondering do you think it's more of
a like a psychological thing you know
listen for me it's very simple
um
I would get an extra hour of sunlight if
the sun was out an hour later that's it
I'm sleeping through that early part
and also it doesn't really bother me to
get up and it's still not fully light
out that would be fine with that
I just want the extra hour later that's
just it's just me you know tell me I'm
crazy I don't know
zailor Avon says call out a town council
member spreading litter box hoax at
meeting she freaked tried to get my
friend fired from private job claimed
she was being harassed so bad a fragile
person would kill herself posted on
subreddit zayler you're shot out of a
cannon today it's I understand you're
talking about the cat litter box School
Story let me check out the subreddit and
see what's going on so see if I can
better understand that okay thanks to
Wesley Taylor for gifting two more
subscriptions at joinpackman.com we are
now at 1 45 for the day and I very very
much appreciate that all right folks uh
let me go over the next few days and a
couple different important things for
about three minutes before the rally
starts
from here on out it's basically streams
every day content content content tick
tocks YouTube twitch the entire thing
there is no problem in my relationship
with Stephen Kenneth Destiny benel II or
with Ian varsh everything is fine people
seem worried it's just been so busy I
haven't been able to have them on
they're both welcome anytime I just sent
Stephen Kenneth Destiny benel II a
message asking if he's streaming tonight
he didn't respond he must not be
streaming or he's busy but they're
welcome anytime and I'm glad to chat
with them and we're part of the
community everybody's part it's all it's
all great okay everything's good
we last month I gave you a piece of
information and it was a piece of
information that to me was very sad
quite frankly it was really a shame to
quote Donald Trump and I know many of
you responded to it as well
and the piece of information I gave you
last month was that despite us having
only about a million and a half
subscribers on YouTube I found out
thanks to my colleague John telling me
this that in September
4.3 million different people looked at
our clips on YouTube okay so do very
very simple math 4.3 million different
people watched Clips only 1.5 million
are subscribed that means that there's
2.8 million people floating around out
there who were watching the Clips and
have not subscribed some of them hate me
okay imagine a million hate me okay this
still leaves over a million folks who
are watching the Clips but just haven't
thought oh I should click the Subscribe
button this might help David and it cost
me nothing by the way
I hate to tell you that the spread has
gotten even worse we just got the
numbers in from October pollster John
McLachlan got them for me no I'm kidding
that's Trump's pollster I just looked in
my YouTube Analytics
4.7 million different people watched our
clips on YouTube in October and we have
only 1.5 million subscribers this means
that out there are 3.2 million people
3.2 million people
who watch the clips but don't subscribe
help us become only the second
Progressive YouTube channel ever to get
to 2 million subscribers
I'm just talking to the people that
already watched the clips
that's it okay there's 3.2 million of
you people it brings me tears
and they call me sir about it and they
say Sir why don't these people subscribe
and I say I don't know I don't know help
me to help you I'm speaking to the 3.2
million of you okay very very important
stuff that's number one secondly uh what
is going to happen on Election night
we're going to cover the results live
results are going to start coming in
I think I am going to start at 7 30 P
East 430 p West and we will go with
tears in my eyes we will go okay
assuming you know I don't get coveted or
something between now and then but that
is the plan that is the plan
the last thing I'm going to mention and
this really is I I know we joke around
about all of it
forget about the me forget about this
show okay
the right is so well funded right now
they are funding
poll Watchers which are really poll
Intimidators they are funding right-wing
media like Charlie Kirk and Candace
Owens and all these different people
they're funding Turning Point USA in
person event the right is funding
everything okay
I don't need you to support this show
although why not but if we don't start
matching what the right is doing when it
comes to Independent Media we're going
to get flushed 5 10 maybe even 15 times
okay so we have a very ambitious goal
here of a thousand website members not
tonight although but let's do it right
but by Tuesday night okay go to
joinpakman.com
the memberships fund this channel the
Pac-Man Live channel the Pacman Finance
Channel
our colleagues who handle Facebook and
Instagram our colleagues who do the tick
tock content we are about to release a
white paper original white paper
on how to talk to people about politics
when they don't know what the f they're
talking about when they go well look I
mean all these people said the election
was stolen
it's going to be a guide to how to
handle that stuff okay the white paper
is almost done free
free we're giving away the white paper
we've all been working on it we got a
writer we've all been okay all this
stuff
all you have to do
is go to joinpakman.com
okay the white paper is free someone
told me the other day white paper
sounded racist like it was a KKK thing
it's just a term it's just white paper
Okay
um hit the sign up button at
joinpakman.com use the coupon code
coupon code above my head is indict okay
you type in the coupon code look at what
it does for you
now here's a secret code this one is
even better
Obama type in the coupon code
this this is like nothing guys okay
we are in the home stretch
I believe Tuesday quite frankly is only
the start
I think Tuesday is the start of what is
going to be the most weaponized
Republican attempt to subvert democracy
in 2024.
and so we're trying to get to Tuesday
but I also think Tuesday is just the
beginning and so I'm coming to you with
peace and love it'll be a free pdf guys
you don't have to ask for it now
when the white paper is out I will tell
you how to get it it will be free it
will be out before Thanksgiving so it'll
be a good framework for people who are
wondering how do I talk to family at
Thanksgiving how do I talk to my uncle
who goes well what about Hunter Biden
it will be a guide
which will tell you exactly how to
figure out those conversations it's
going to be great all right so we're
here I appreciate everybody who's here
let me do a little bit of okay I mean
call it a brown paper I don't even care
we'll color the background of the PDF
whatever color people want yeah it'll be
a great by the way
the white paper might be an interesting
gift
give the white paper away to people
that's I like that idea very very much
okay super chats and different things
are coming in the blah just gifted five
YouTube subscriptions putting us at 150.
I appreciate that
over on Twitch Frank morning tree just
gifted five subscriptions putting us at
155. I also want to say thanks to
weatherboxer who puts us at 156 and then
over on the website
I have to thank so many great people
Wesley Taylor who just gifted another
three subscriptions
Sean fertel and then Wesley Taylor with
another one that's five Wesley Taylor
six and seven
and Wesley Taylor eight
Wesley Taylor is an All-Star tonight
that puts us at 164 and I really
appreciate that Trump imminently will be
speaking it is for those of you hoping
for a short speech based on the weather
it is chilly in Sioux City Iowa but it
is 45 degrees I don't think that's cold
enough that Trump will
sort of take pity on us take Mercy on us
and keep it as a short speech I believe
he could go 90 or even 100 minutes
tonight
he's eight minutes late it looks like he
is arriving and hopefully we'll be
speaking uh very very soon that is uh
that's the hope the sooner he starts the
sooner he ends is what they tell me
thanks to Cod Fisher for the twitch
Prime subscription as well very very
much appreciate that people wondering
where did Trump's lawyer go and who is
this new host I have no clue and his
sophisticated to him
um that they stuck with him and they're
helping him with these things and I mean
you wouldn't know any different they
they are so professional they are able
to you know carry out these events and
yeah very very exciting thanks to
symbolic gamer and irie man for the
twitch Prime subscriptions
Holly says just subscribed and joined
thank you Holly and in fact thanks to
Garrett Woodard Casey Katie
Bonnie Carpenter
Sheridan bernasconi and Wesley Taylor
really appreciate that putting us at 172
for the day this is the first of four
Trump rallies coming up in the next five
days let me give you the schedule
tonight Trump is in Sioux City Iowa
Saturday
Trump will be in oh I don't even know
where you know what I don't it's Florida
Ohio and
hold on a second let me let me get this
for you
events
okay
Saturday Trump will be in Latrobe
Pennsylvania on behalf of Doug mastriano
and Quack Dr Mehmet Oz
Sunday he will be in Miami Florida on
behalf of Marco Rubio but not Ron death
santis he death santis is excluded
because he and Trump are feuding and
then Monday November 7th the eve of the
2022 midterms Trump will be in Dayton
Ohio supporting uh what was that guy's
name that he was going to be supporting
we've endorsed JP right JD Mandel no JD
Vance is who he's actually supporting I
don't know that he really knows that
that will be on Monday interspersed with
this Saturday President Barack Obama is
going to be with John fetterman
and election results Tuesday endless
folks endless endless endless stuff
thank you to Matthew Rogers Kyoko awaya
our good friend Kyoko from Tokyo Robin
tills Carrie Perrone and Raphael Liss
for signing up at joinpakman.com putting
us at 177 really appreciate the support
coming in from everybody it's going to
be a very very packed five days
on the edge of my seat tonight David
hoping Trump will stand up and help
rehabilitate his pal Kanye who I hear
has some trouble with Jewish yes Kanye
was very he said some very tough things
on Jewish as Donald Trump said in that
very strange interview yesterday I grew
up in the area where Trump is speaking
says Eric there's a reason I don't live
there anymore unfortunately people there
eat up as nonsense
Alexander says hey David does anyone
track if the Trump campaign still
refuses to pay for their rally locations
I don't know the answer to that it's a
good question Trump uh I think he still
owes like El Paso money from a rally
five years ago he just doesn't pay
just does not pay it's it's really
something else
thanks to carbon debates for the twitch
Prime subscription putting us at 178.
also I can't even believe what is
happening on the website and what
happened they call them dumps yeah
memberships are dumping in I want to say
thanks to Jason Edson as well as Frank
Allen Kyoko gifting another subscription
Wesley gifting another one Scott Fisher
has signed up and Randy Smith is a new
member that's one two three four five
that's six if my math serves me 178 plus
6 is 184.
the goal of a thousand is through
Tuesday
maybe we'll get there sooner and we'll
go for two thousand the rally any moment
people are worried did I miss the rally
you did not miss the rally would I be
here if the rally were over
I'd be I'd be reading in bed
um the rally is about to start it's 13
minutes overdue let's listen to a little
bit of the coverage from right side
Broadcasting
2.0 is what this is it may be even worse
yeah maybe even worse there's no
evidence of any of that we ignore mental
health in this country yeah we ignore
mental health we're Health we're talking
about
we actually talk about it all the time
in the context of the magicalists are
ignorant
brainwashed
and some are mentally ill we we actually
talk about it all the time
but these people want to talk about Paul
Pelosi she's doing in that District I
don't I don't get it and I am not
calling for violence against anyone
let's be crystal clear on that but the
notion they want to keep we're really
coddling it we're not calling for it
we're merely coddling it these rallies
guys
is it inappropriate for me to say that
these rallies are a celebration of both
mental illness and cultishness
is Trump coming out is that what's going
on okay so we got a little bit of the uh
well we got some of the press core
coming through there I don't if I'm yeah
oh boy it is it's sick it's sick I feel
proud to be the first to call him Agent
Orange from anyone around me or before I
saw it on the web
says trumpet thank you trumpet great to
have you here folks I can't thank you
enough I am I am flattered and humbled
by the support that is dumping in on my
website thanks to Elise Barba Kyoko
Wesley gifting another one Kyoko gifting
another one Brian peronto with a new
membership Wesley gifting another one
and then Michael Sylvia
that is absolutely incredible that is
seven more putting us at 191
if you want a free membership folks I
have them to give away go to
davidpackman.com free membership in the
order you request them we will give them
away we've given away over a thousand
free memberships so far actually I think
it's like 900.
about 900 something like that
super chats keep coming in everybody
that has time should phone bank get
those gen ziers out to vote save America
from the fascists with rhetoric voters
of tomorrow yes thank you
massive dump says Jackson Warren beers
absolutely
uh you have choices tonight you could
get the free Trump book the kids guide
to Trump
I don't recommend that
uh or you could re-up your Twitch Prime
subscription the way just Jamie and
carbon debates just did
you know which one I recommend that's
for damn sure
that is for damn sure couple other
voicemails coming in let's listen
hey Dave it's John
uh
um watching your uh live feed for uh
from Trump rally in Iowa yes in Sioux
City but anyway you were talking about
your page and you should call it
Spectrum Spectrum page or Spectrum
Papyrus whatever but Spectrum it covers
all colors so no if I call the white
paper a spectrum Papyrus I will probably
lose my entire audience people will
think I'm completely off the wall nuts
okay so I have to keep calling it a
white paper
David sir
this is Wes from Detroit
I gotta say the white papers are a great
ideal and I can't wait for them yep
thank you thank you see now folks I
think that that's the same Wes who just
dumped in 15 memberships to be perfectly
Frank the white paper will be out soon
very very much in time for uh for
Thanksgiving conversations thanks to
Palisade and high-end milk for the
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
195 really appreciate that uh Gigi thank
you very much for joining us from Europe
with a super chat Trump is only about 17
minutes late right now my desire would
be for Trump to start no later than 8 30
Eastern and to speak no longer than 90
minutes so we can be done by 10 Eastern
that would be my goal uh I would also
love it if it just started pouring and
he called the entire speech off that
would be nice too thanks to Frank
Haggerty for signing up on my website as
well as Charlie Davidson Wesley Taylor
gifting one more membership thanks to
Dylan Lucas the great Christopher
peoples Wesley Taylor gifting another
one thanks to Harvey Warnick William
Shuster and Wesley Taylor with yet
another gift that is an additional eight
memberships putting us at 203 folks this
is extraordinary I am humbled by the
support at this critical time for
Independent Media the goal is a thousand
by election night we are already at 203
and thanks to existential eight ball we
are now at 204 existential eight ball
asking any updates on Eric Coomer I
don't know does anybody know what
happened to Eric Coomer
anybody have any idea I don't I don't
have any idea
I'm seeing Bernie speak Sunday in Philly
really scared about the midterms do you
think Dems have any chance you just vote
guys just vote my opinion doesn't matter
just vote
um
if anybody can email me the info on the
Bernard Sanders Sunday rally I'm willing
to do double coverage folks
we're streaming 24 7 it sounds like
until Tuesday uh if the Bernie rally
follows the Rubio rally on Sunday I will
cover both okay email me the info if you
have it thanks to Sean for gifting five
subscriptions via YouTube I appreciate
that also thanks to high-end milk for
gifting five via twitch
I I don't need you to tell me in the
chat about the Bernie rally just email
me the info about the Bernie rally and I
will cover it I think that would be a
great great thing to cover why not
hi David um this is Destiny from
Oklahoma and I just for one wanted to
say I'm clocking off of how you say um
Kevin stitt's name
yeah the Oklahoma governor Kevin's tit
that's not his name how you say Kevin's
tit it's amazing also I wanted to point
out the cool Dynamic that's going on
between
um the Democrat Challenger
because she was actually a republican up
until maybe a year or so ago
um so anyways being a former Republican
she actually has quite a bit of support
um from the list trumpy Republicans in
our state which I I work with a few
because I worked at a hospital but
anyway um I want to just give that
caveat about the Oklahoma Oklahoma
governor's race because
it's pretty close and so we're watching
it close please yeah we've been watching
it very very very closely David sir I
have been listening to the Trump tapes
with tears in my ears they are
something else and I will be sending you
some nice sound clips for your
soundboard from this this is Rusty in
Oklahoma signing officer I appreciate
that that would be really great I would
love to have that thanks to c-man for
the twitch subscription and thanks to S
press for gifting 12. that's a total of
13. 13 plus 214 by my math puts us at
227. uh continuing to see uh super chats
and things coming in
Daniel says elements of Jewish yeah it
was really weird the other day when
Trump said
Kanye was very rough on Jewish let me
see if I can find it here it was a
bizarre bizarre way to say it
um
here it is check check this out this is
which is weird why can't he talk
normally about anything I was very
honored in a sense because he uh you
know he said all those great things
about being Tucker Carlson
uh he made some statements rough
statements uh on Jewish you heard them
and you know them well yeah
why why can't he just speak normally
about anything
he made rough statements on Jewish
Dear God
what a nightmare
uh look if you don't vote because you
think we can't win then we definitely
won't go vote that's exactly right Genie
if you stay home because you're like oh
we're not going to win
staying home will make us not win that's
exactly right you could could not
possibly say it better myself
thanks to geostigma for gifting a
subscription on Twitch folks the website
is coming under heavy load right now due
to people dumping in memberships thanks
to Wesley Taylor for gifting another two
actually three Simon Cunningham just
signed up Mario Jimenez just signed up
Wesley Taylor Mario Jimenez gifting
another one that is five more putting us
at 235. that's a stunning that's a
crooked number
as we say in baseball and thanks to
Queen's Gambit for re-upping over on
Twitch imminently the Trump rally will
start let me know in the chat are they
going to do the Q Anon music thing where
Trump talks about how bad things are in
the United States today are they doing
the Q and on music today let me know
what do people think
dear God mostly yeses I guess we're
screwed
yeah
it does I think people
people seem pretty convinced it's
happening that's
sad for me I guess
um I just moved to Florida from the
sixth district in New Jersey says Paul I
still oh no no I'm from New Jersey six
months ago I still get text alerts from
New Jersey FBI is on alert for threats
against synagogues crazy times very much
so
thanks to Reed for the Super Chat
appreciate that very very much as well
yeah it's uh people seem convinced we're
getting the Q music today
people seem convinced
a couple other voicemails
sure let's listen
hi David Renee from Michigan I just
wanted to let you know that I already
submitted my ballot and I voted for big
Gretch so hard that my pen almost ripped
through the ballot and also Yes on Prop
three
all right very very important message
Renee from Michigan has voted
hey David uh Pennsylvania called a
couple times
I just want to talk about the Oz
race in Pennsylvania what amazes me is
like when Obama
reelection or his legitimacy legitimacy
is a a United States citizen not living
in the United States
and yet the Republicans have the gall
to vote for Oz who doesn't even live in
Pennsylvania yeah so one way you know
don't vote for this guy but when it's
our guy doesn't even live here and I'm
from Pennsylvania it blows my mind
just the lunacy of the Republican Party
Guys this isn't unique I mean they say
they're against abortion Herschel Walker
urged two women to get abortions paid
for them threatened one of them
implicitly by saying that neither She
nor the child would be safe if she
doesn't abort
and they're like I was a youthful
indiscretion it was he was 50.
I played a clip of that on the show the
other day
absolutely nuts people demanding a
Whitney voicemail I don't know that I
have one
uh uh
let's see if I have a Whitney voicemail
um Whitney I don't know that she's been
calling in that much lately
yeah I'm not seeing anything from
Whitney
oh look
let me say
I'm a Jewish used car salesman but I'm
not a real salesman all my cars are by
owner this is the Eggman it's a hobby so
when I sell a car to somebody I give
them a bill of sale
and they can put any price on there that
they want that they have to pay tax in
in New York state right I sell cars to
all kinds of people
um a lot of the Mexican people I'm a lot
of hillbilly white people all the white
people put down a very low amount for
their uh for the price so they can pay
much less tax all the Hispanic and
Mexican people put down the exact price
because they are terrified of doing
anything illegal yeah that's the exact
crime Trump has been accused of by
undervaluing his properties when he
wants the um when he wants to pay tax on
them but he overvalues them and he wants
to use them to leverage them okay so
I noticed that Mexican people are not
nearly as criminal as Donald Trump
shalom shalom Eggman yeah that's an
interesting completely anecdotal
observation from the Eggman selling used
cars in upstate rural rural as Donald
Trump says Upstate New York a very very
powerful observation from the Eggman
Greg asks did I ever get my desk
situation figured out thanks for all the
shows and streams yeah so for the studio
rebuild uh we are I I'm basically
there's a there's a bunch of companies
that just make they're kind of like the
default companies for standing desks
it's like autonomous.ai uplift very desk
you know whatever the products are very
similar what I decided to do
here's the thing about the desks okay
and maybe somebody uh in the in the
audience can help me with this
particular detail here I have two desks
why do I have two desks well one reason
is I want to be further from the camera
if I only had one desk the camera would
be right here so I have my cameras
behind the second desk but here's the
critical thing this microphone is not
mounted to this desk if the microphone
arm was on this desk when I type or when
I use my mouse I would get sound
transfer the way I deal with that is I
have a second desk where this microphone
is mounted so I'm going to get the super
wide like an 80 incher
Rising desk solid very solid that will
be my main desk for my monitors but
I need a solution without two desks
because it's a little clunky to have two
desks for mounting the microphone
one person said well if you're near a
wall
I could do a wall mount for the mic and
it would but I don't really want to
damage the wall in that way okay and I
see someone saying it right now so if
anybody has other ideas one idea was I
take a little desk and I make an l
and that's where I mount the microphone
but then you gotta weigh it down so it's
not you know it's stable I need to think
about that so if people have ideas where
do I mount the death the mic to prevent
sound transfer
I could use a boom stand and arm off the
ground right but you get a boom stand
now I need a sandbag so that it won't
tip over and it's very unsightly it's
very unsightly we want it
we want everything clean I don't want uh
that you know what I mean so I'm going
to have to figure that out
a good sturdy mic stand separate from
your desk
yeah
do the smaller desk but keep the PC on
it to weigh it down
the problem with that is then I need
cables long enough to adjust if the PC
isn't mounted underneath the standing
desk then I'm screwed I could have an
employee hold the mic the entire time
that idea I like
that idea I like
and people are saying use a noise gate
for the low frequencies doesn't work I
have a Noise Gate the problem is these
are literal Taps on the same thing that
this is attached to anyway email me info
davidpackman.com uh a mic stand off of
the floor sounds a little bit
unprofessional I don't know that I love
that I don't know that I love that
switch to a lapel body mic no no guys
this is the mic okay I like the way this
mic sounds I've got it dialed in I've
got all my stuff this is the mic I know
I have other mics but this is the mic I
want to use
pull drop a pole dancing pole from the
floor to ceiling and attach it that's
not a bad idea
uh
uh right people are like just get a
completely different mic now this is the
mic use a bedside dresser I know that's
the obvious thing put up just put a
random piece of furniture off to the
side and attach it to that but I want
anything to look nice it needs to look
nice use a headset Mike thanks guys
really appreciate it really appreciate
it thanks to Silo and amperecy for the
twitch Prime subscriptions as we stand
by here I want to say thank you to
people signing up on my website
including Linda tremel
Laura Briggs Richard Wyatt Mario Jimenez
who is signing up endlessly Wesley
Taylor gifting more and more and more
subscriptions Kevin John as well as
Thomas Keith a total of let me see if
I've got this right
12. folks we're at 250 and it is day one
of five leading up to these incredible
elections
um I'm so excited to witness this Cirque
de Coupe
yes Brian absolutely
that's quite a quite a statement I must
say Donald Trump is now a half hour late
um
let's see what else we've got in of your
voicemails
what's this yesterday I got to put my
vote in for Beto
there was no line I was surprised
I mean I literally walked in voted and
left and went back to work I did it on
my lunch break that's good that it was
so convenient Kimmy but not so good that
uh it seems like turnout is not
particularly High there but we're gonna
watch that very closely folks thank you
to dirty Curda
for subscribing via twitch Prime and
thank you to S Prez for the massive dump
of 50 more subscriptions putting us at
301 for the day
Charlie asking what's the over under on
Trump having bizarre knock knees tonight
yeah it was at the last rally Trump came
out and his knees were touching but his
feet were like two feet away from each
other
it was very strange I I never noticed
him being knock-kneed before
uh but we're gonna look at it how many
memberships has s Perez gifted I can
tell you s Perez has gifted two thousand
404 memberships on Twitch
uh pushing Skittle stew down to second
place and inconsolable down to third
place David chadman in fourth place at
this particular point in time
what is today's coupon code folks it's
right there
today's coupon code is indict
but I have a better code for you if you
use the code Obama Obama
it's like a greater than 66 percent
discount I think it's like I think it's
a 70 discount
is it a 69 discount yeah rough it's
roughly 70. sure if it'll make you
happier
say that it's a 69 discount sure what
about a shock mount for the mic yeah
um that's a possibility you could get a
shock mount the problem is I have a
shock mount on my EVR E20
and it's just not the best it's not the
best all right now they're playing a
video so Trump's probably coming out
very very soon
thanks to the XC and ghost rooster live
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
um they're playing video of trump I
guess at the inauguration while these
people this really is a cult huh making
trouble still
[Music]
oh my God very very cultish really wacky
have you considered training your baby
to hold the mic she is now holding stuff
she's now holding stuff I mean the
problem is she puts everything in her
mouth right now so I'm trying to keep
electronic equipment away from her
thanks to Jason and sigmeyer for gifting
a membership on my website folks
I'm going to take a breath
if you want a free membership
go to davidpackman.com
free membership
okay
they go in order of signing up I see two
emails right now from people saying
can you get me a free membership
and you have to put in your name guys
guys please please
davidpackman.com free membership we are
moments away from trump it appears as
though he will be joining us any second
joining us any second let's see
do it
all right as we get
well that that guy's got to turn the
game down on his mic that's pretty
weaponized stuff Mario Jimenez has
gifted two more subscriptions I think
he's just gifting them because I'm
saying his last name Jimenez
um why are people saying Brazil isn't
Latin America is Portuguese not a Latin
based language yeah it's
it doesn't that that's not why it's just
there's this thing where Brazil is
considered part of South America but not
part of Latin America
Latin as in Latino not it's
just it doesn't it's not even worth
worrying about it's just what it is you
know it
I I it sometimes people go why is it
called anti-Semitism because Arabs are
semites too
Semite and anti-Semitism are two
different things anti-Semitism
specifically is a word meaning
anti-jewish
in the same way Brazil is not considered
part of Latin America it's you know I
mean I I I I didn't create this stuff
I didn't create this stuff
hey David I just thought I'd share Kevin
McCarthy that dude reached out to me
offered me 10 bucks to park oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa oh my God I just read I just
read ahead the transcript what this
person is about to say I I cannot play
that that is that is vile and completely
gross okay
you can use your imagination about where
that was going God I'm glad I read ahead
on that one that could have been
that might have cut all of the streams
that we're doing right now
dude still watching this show it's John
again
um either do a drop mic or use an
umbrella stand cast iron umbrella stand
and get that mount in there some way I'm
sure you're engineered enough to do that
huh but a cast iron umbrella stand will
hold that thing up all over the place
and you won't get sound transfer anyway
later
an umbrella stand
uh
what is an umbrella stand is that a
stand for an umbrella light
yeah they make it's just all these
floor-based mic stands seem very shaky
very very they just seem weak
I need power
I need strength
As Trump says with great strength
uh yeah
hey David I don't want you to lose hope
my aunt who is my mother sister who
talks like this I mean the Agnes and
hillbilly
and um the other day she was saying you
know I was doing some research on that
Oz guy Dr Oz and man
I would never vote for him and I said
you were what you were researching
oh my gosh I'm so proud of you because
over the last three four years I said
just like you know research and she goes
I ain't gonna be doing none of that I
don't need to I'm not interested well
good thing that she did that's for sure
the orange Menace is making his entrance
as you can see here uh he will soon be
speaking and it's going to be pretty
ugly that's for sure
yeah uh Cody says some lady told my mom
the gay Pelosi conspiracy I sent her
your debunking clip and I quote I like
this David Pacman he's handsome and well
spoken why can't you get a haircut like
his sounds like you've got a new fan
thank you Cody I appreciate that say hi
to your mom for me that's a very very
nice thing to say
uh very very powerful I must say we will
be hearing from Donald Trump momentarily
uh we are streaming every rally every
day it's going to be completely crazy
make sure you are indeed subscribed on
YouTube this is the number of YouTube
subscribers that we have it's not the
best number but it is ours and that is
exactly what matters David the voicemail
said cast iron stand
okay
cast iron stand
die cast
Black cast iron weighted microphone
stand oh waited I could go for that
a weighted microphone stand that's not a
terrible idea
um what do we do if Republicans decide
to use violence to gain political power
it seems we're getting closer to more
political violence aren't they kind of
already doing it all right let's listen
as bad as it's going to be
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry
[Applause]
I want to just say it's cold out here
but not that bad cut it shortly I said
do you think I need a hat they said you
might be better off with a hat
I wanted to show you this beautiful hair
tonight but what the hell I'll show it
I'll get it I'll lift that hat up
sometime but I want to just thank
everybody and hello to Sioux City it's
been uh fantastic we were here a long
time ago and it started things off and
we've had uh some fun making our country
great again and then unfortunately we
had a roadblock with this character
these people that are there now it's a
disgrace what's happened to our country
but I'm thrilled to be back in the great
state of Iowa with thousands of proud
hard-working American Patriots
just five days from now the people of I
were going to re-elect your legendary
set he's a legend you know Chuck
Grassley first time I met him
a legend in his own mind about politics
I said man this guy's tough
now he's the greatest I'll tell you he's
become a great friend of mine he's uh
like no other Chuck Grassley so uh get
him in there I think he's not gonna have
a problem but uh now I know after this
tonight he's not going to have a problem
and also you're going to re-elect one of
the great governors in our country Kim
Reynolds as your
as your representative Governor she's
been incredible everything she does it
just works and you're going to vote for
an incredible slate of true America
First Republicans up and down the ballot
and we're going to end crazy Nancy
Pelosi's political career once oh God
right right is this the right thing to
be talking about are you the greatest
what a job you do get ready for the
White House Jeff
under Biden Pelosi Schumer the radical
democrat congress the Iowa way of life
is under siege and it is a great way of
life a beautiful way of life Biden and
the far left lunatics are Waging War in
Iowa Farmers crushing American Energy
attacking Iowa ethanol and strangling
Iowa families with soaring prices and
there's never been a president better to
really I think I can say to any of these
that was a glitch there has is that
right Eric
there has never been a president that
has been better to the farmers or better
to Iowa
than Trump
okay
right inflation is costing the typical
Iowa household 700 every single month
think of it 700 inflation you had no
inflation with us yet no problems with
anything frankly the southern border is
wide open millions of illegal aliens are
pouring in a level that nobody's ever
seen before and I think that includes
any other country
violent crime is out of control the far
left is indoctrinating our children with
Twisted race and gender lunacy in our
schools oh no and just moments ago a
radical left lunatic judge in New York
City is totally controlled by my worst
enemies in the Democrat Party
and by the New York attorney general
there's another Beauty
who was given his position by them at
the request of the out of control
attorney general who's let violent crime
in New York rage in the state including
murders robberies rape and drugs at
levels never seen before started a
process of property confiscation that is
akin to Venezuela Cuba or the old Soviet
Union it's uh communism what's going on
in our country they're weaponizing the
justice department they've weaponized
things that were not supposed to be
weaponized companies are already fleeing
New York as you probably read you don't
have to worry about it here that I can
tell you but now they will be leaving
even faster what they're doing in New
York is unbelievably sad and it's all
coming from Washington D.C you know that
there's only one choice to end this
madness if you support the decline and
fall of America then vote for the
radical left Democrats it's very simple
and if you want to stop destruction and
save our country and save the American
dream then this Tuesday you must vote
Republican in a giant red wave giant red
flag
there's no more urgent to ask for our
future future of our country than to
stop The Invasion and that's what it is
is like a military Invasion many of
these people are coming out of jails
from other countries they're dumping
their prisoners into the United States
but we're going to stop it and we stop
it the greatest border the safest border
in the history of our country we can
have to do it again anybody know what
Invasion he's referring to it's revealed
that this September set yet another
all-time record high in illegal border
crossings with a quarter of a million
illegal what he means is people were
caught doesn't that mean we're stopping
them stop order in one month we've never
had numbers like this and it's getting
bigger and bigger and bigger we said
every record during the summer and
that's very hot they really come in
during the fall during the winter you're
going to see numbers that you've never
seen I believe you're gonna have 10
million people at least
two years ago
yeah we did and we built the wall and
then we added more and by the way two
and a half years they stopped with legal
and we wanted all that we got it built
and that's why we had the best numbers
in the history of our country two years
ago we had the strongest Southern Border
in American history now it's the worst
border I believe in the world because I
don't believe that any third world
country would allow to happen what's
happening to us I don't believe that and
there's Uncle Sam stand up please Uncle
Sam
it's the greatest he's a great hook and
he's the real deal you know he follows
me around and I like him and he's
Central Casting you are a handsome uncle
said cult leader likes the cult members
what a shock
he's great great guy great Patriot Biden
Pelosi and the radical Democrats spend
all their time obsessing over the
borders of distant foreign nations of
many people here have never even heard
of
and Americans deserve to have a Congress
and a president who will protect our
borders of our nation right don't you
think
we deserve a government that will defend
our sovereignty secure our land stand up
for our families and protect the people
of our country it's called very simply
America first we want America to come
first
this year more Americans will die of
Fentanyl and drug overdose and the
number of ukrainians killed in the
gruesome and bloody war that by the way
would have never happened
it was that's what a horrible thing is
going on over there yet Biden and the
radical Democrats do nothing at all to
stop the death and Devastation caused by
this Invasion into our country since the
end of the Trump Administration the drug
cartels have seen their revenue
Skyrocket by an astounding 2 500 percent
would you say that's a lot
from 500 million dollars a year and we
were bringing it down we had the best
years in 31 years on stopping drugs
stopping human trafficking and all other
things
but they went up 2 500 percent
and it's uh now a 13 billion dollar a
year industry can you believe it it's
like an industry the choice this
selection is very simple Democrats will
defund the police Republicans will to
fund the cartels and we were doing that
there's been no police defunding ship we
wage war on the cartels we ended Catch
and Release we stopped Asylum fraud and
we threw a legal alien gang members out
of our country by the tens of thousands
and we got their countries to accept
them they wouldn't take them under the
previous administration we got them to
accept I said how much do we pay those
countries three countries you know the
countries
sure it's 750 million dollars a year I
said tell them we're not sure unless
they take them back and they said sir
we'd love to take them back nobody's
ever answered us quite that way
not quite that way we built hundreds of
miles of border wall and despite two and
a half years of democrat lawsuits to
stop it we won all of them and we got it
built we completely finished our
original plan and then added the
original plan was a wall across the
entire U.S Mexico border which Mexico
would pay for Mexico paid for nothing
and the wall across the entire border
was not built going on
thanks to the open borders policies of
the radical Democrats every day American
Community there is no open borders
policy the killing of innocent life
earlier this year an illegal alien
criminal was sentenced to brutally
stabbing to death a 33 year old man and
leaving his guys the audio problems are
starting we were we were hoping and
they're starting
oh God Cedar Rapids we have great
memories of Cedar Rapids but that's a
real bad thing really bad in the
sanctuary City of Chicago an illegal
alien was recently arrested for savagely
shooting an innocent 41 year old father
in the head at Point Blank Range and
didn't think anything of it like nothing
happened do you hear those weeks ago an
illegal alien was sentenced for stabbing
a New York City police officer in the
neck and stealing his gun to shoot other
police officers which he did he went on
a rampage when Republicans we take
control of Congress we must immediately
Force the restoration of every single
Trump border security measure that
achieved the strongest Border in the
history of our country by far
right
right instead of doubling the number of
IRS agents we should double the number
of ice and border patrol agents remember
that the number of Ira IRS agencies and
doubling uh 55 000 are expected to
retire over the next 10 years there's a
plan to replace them and add a little
bit more we have to give law enforcement
back
what they do they do it better than
anybody else give them the respect that
they deserve these are incredible people
I met a lot of them backstage
and they're very thankful I get every
one of them to endorse us they know
exactly what's going on and we we were
doing things on crime that nobody
thought were possible but we're gonna
have to think about doing it again very
shortly aren't we huh we should pass
legislation to deport every illegal
alien that Joe Biden is unlawfully
allowed to break into our country
and we're going to make America great
again we first have to make America safe
again
okay
you can't walk down a sidewalk in
Chicago get hit over the head with a
baseball bat from behind and say gee we
live in a wonderful place and that's
what's happening people you see they're
being shoved into subway trains trains
coming along 40 miles an hour boom
a man shoved right into the train these
people it's uh horrible horrible thing
for everybody just coming in the audio
problems are native to the event it is
not something on our stream Law and
Order but with our police when we give
them back their tools and you know what
the tools are it's up here the tools is
nobody can do it better than them you'll
have Law and Order again you'll have
respect you have to respect the police
right now of a policeman
speaks a little bit loudly Trump's like
respect the police also and the FBI CIA
Etc don't care about the Capitol Police
on January 6. left Democrats the streets
of our cities are ruled by bloodthirsty
gangs and violent criminals much of the
crime wave is caused by drug dealers who
during the course of their lives will
kill an average of 500 Americans so you
have a drug dealer he or she Trump has
repeated this claim dozens of times
there is no evidence that every drug
dealer kills 500 Americans it's insane
at its face and there is no such
evidence of that
on its passage reduce drug distribution
and crime the first day by 75 crime will
go down because so much of our crime is
caused by these people you go to places
like China here we go and uh many many I
don't want to get into it because we
don't want to be too controversial but
you go to China you go to Singapore
China many countries where they have the
death penalty they had no drug problem
whatsoever
the drug deal says no let's go to the
United States a much nicer way
to live
now we have to do it not that we want to
do it nobody wants to talk about that
but if we're going to have a country
we're going to have is it just me or is
the audio getting even worse in Congress
we must also pass critical funding to
hire thousands more police officers
Nationwide to put violent criminals
Behind Bars and to keep them behind bars
and I see all those incredible people
back there are they allowed to move up
here in front of the fake news I mean
it's there's thousands of people
can they be allowed come on now it's
fine suddenly
look at all of them they go so far you
can't even see and and you know I think
they could let some people up here in
fact it'll make you a little bit warmer
you know it'll be you'll be a little
closer together if they can and I see
some great police officers back if they
could let those people come forward it
would be great throws a family
we're all a big family yeah let them
come look they go so far back there's
plenty of space this angers me when we
give the fake news a better position
than a people way back
foreign
they have these telescopic lenses Kim
that they can be back another hundred
yards and people can enjoy it more would
you let them back in come on let them
get up because if you want safety for
your family and security for your
community you need to throw every
Democrat the hell out of office and vote
for Republicans up and down the line
one of the worst and most Sinister
aspects of the Biden Administration is
their complete and total Corruption of
our justice system and the rule of law
before our very eyes Biden and his left
wing handlers are turning America into a
police state like something straight out
of a communist country the radical
Democrats are locking up pro-life
activists persecuting their political
opponents nobody can believe this is
happening Kim it's happening at a level
that nobody can believe they even raided
Mar-A-Lago can you believe it they
raided Mar-A-Lago yes sir tell you what
I'd like to do
spying on their political rival
silencing dissent and using the full
force of government law enforcement and
the media to try and defeat the greatest
movement in the history of our country
mega mega Biden's really been going why
are you guys questioning that Democrats
want to install a police state while
simultaneously defunding the police
which they didn't actually do come on
guys just accept it then your Supreme
Court ruled in effect
that the 2020 presidential election was
rigged you saw this just happened this
week they stated that the things that
took place with the ballots in 2020 were
not allowed they weren't allowed oh good
that means we won right no but they
refused to rule against invalidating the
election but they said but in the future
they say these fraudulent acts election
irregularities and infractions cannot be
done anymore that's wonderful that's
isn't that a terrible thing so they
agree that it was rigged now and by the
way Wisconsin so many states are now
finding it this thing was rigged but
they are not finding that you wouldn't
let this happen so Pennsylvania rules
and strongly that okay it was wrong and
by the way far more votes than needed
for victory very close I was up almost a
million votes at 10 o'clock in the
evening with 73 percent of the vote in
then all of a sudden boom it's a
disgrace what's going on between the
borders and the elections
I need 11 000 votes give me a break but
they say it only matters for future
elections the number of votes discussed
as I just said was far more than needed
to win and this was only in one form of
cheating this was one form of cheating
there's so many there's so many you can
almost not count
this is a very unfair thing to your
favorite President but what the hell
I've been treated so unfairly what the
hell difference does it make at this
point
now your favorite President
your favorite President excuse me to all
those young people your favorite
President got screwed
that's what happened
I got gas
hold on I'm coming
become
wow
thank you very much that's true it's
true
we love Trump are they saying
[Applause]
thank you very much that's very nice
thank you very much you know it's a sad
thing because look what's happened to
our country in two years look nobody can
even believe what's happened to our
country true every freedom-loving
American needs to understand the time to
stand up to get this whole thing right
and to stop the left wing tyranny is
right now so if you want to save your
rights and Liberties you have to start
the left is installing tyranny with no
police because they defunded it hmm
weird to the radical left this election
coming up right now
so Tuesday you have to crush the
Communists and go out to The Ballot Box
that's easy there are none I used to say
socialism right they've skipped over
socialism
their socialism is just that was just a
little waste Station right Jeff they've
gone much further than that this is
terrible what's happening is cerebral we
got to stop it for six straight years
the witch hunts hoaxes and abuses have
been coming Fast and Furious like
nobody's ever seen before and they'll
finish one the Adam shifts of the world
right Adam Shifty shift
and you win you win you keep winning you
win but it takes time and effort and
everything but you win
two weeks later they come up with
another hoax right they come up with the
document hooks or they come up with
anyone of a lot Russia Russia Russia
first we learned the Spy to my campaign
remember this but can you imagine never
spied on Biden's campaign or Obama's
campaign it would be like let's wheel
out the election remember that what
happened is that the FBI was carrying
out investigations of suspected
criminals Trump's campaign was in touch
with suspected criminals and so they
were incidentally caught up in
recordings it's an incredible story
actually and not at all what Trump
claims you know they want to double up
and triple up your taxes they have not
been able to break through they have not
been able to do it but they do they want
to Triple the taxes on the very rich
it'll go from 37 percent to what is that
104 you're gonna you're gonna owe four
percent more than you even earn it's
gonna be crazy and they lied to the fisa
court you know they lied five times to
the fisa court and created the fake
dossier that was done and paid for by
crooked Hillary Clinton the Democrats
the Democrat National Committee
the party itself
in conjunction I hate to say it I'm so
because I have so many friends there's
so many people that are great in
conjunction with the FBI you like that
and yet after all of that these same
people come after me they come after me
Trump trump they created all these
hoaxes all these Shams remember it was
Russia Russia Russia Ukraine Ukraine
Ukraine and then the Mueller Witch Hunt
where the conclusion was no collusion do
you think Biden could say that the
conclusion was no collusion I don't
think it I would have a hard time with
that one
and then it was impeachment hoax number
one impeachment hoax number two
the censorship of the Biden family
corruption story as the Russian
disinformation right the Russian
the FBI went to Facebook and they said
oh this is Russian District don't do
anything this is Russian disinformation
on the laptop from hell they said it was
Russian disinformation
to pass out he can't stand they said
this is crazy he's hearing these things
and it's driving him crazy right Uncle
Sam this was not that there he goes by
Sam
now this was not the way it was supposed
to happen Uncle Sam right okay this who
would believe this if you ever wrote it
in a novel nobody would believe it the
corruptness but they went up to Facebook
and they said this is Russia
disinformation and you could look at
that thing and that was not disinformed
nobody could make this information that
good but it wasn't true and it made a
point of I guess it was about 17 points
different and if you think it's easy
being up here with this wind what is he
talking about and I got these stupid
teleprompters waving like a flag you
could have
Kim you think this is easy doing this
out yeah don't tell
I'm gonna get seasick I'm getting
seasick the teleprompter's
I said hopefully he'll end the speech
early so the time the best speeches oh
just give them up and we just wrap it
out right
something which doesn't work very well
for Biden
no now these suckers are moving around
pretty good I'm trying to follow him and
I'm getting seasick up here
and that it was the unselect committee
of political physics and also the
appalling misconduct by the racist and
incompetent New York State Attorney
General Leticia peekaboo James who is
presiding oh God a record number of
murders rapes drug deals and every other
form of crime in our once great New York
state which is going to hell it's going
to hell it's a crime written that we
have a good man lee zeldon lee Selden
horrible
but she only spends her time going after
Trump let's get Trump it's good for my
election let's get Trump in the meantime
I mean what's happening in New York
because we have these incompetent people
they don't even know what they're doing
they have no concept of violence crime
and how to stop it likewise a local
left-wing D.A in Atlanta is after me for
now this really is like when I you know
at a dinner party I get stuck with
someone who just like won't let me walk
away and just talks Non-Stop about a
hundred different things none of which
makes sense and you just like can't
escape and eventually you just have to
pretend to either fall down or just
excuse yourself to the bathroom he
possibly police say no it was a perfect
call be it better than my first perfect
call remember they impeached me on a
perfect call
even while Atlanta is among the highest
murder rates of any city in the country
by the way per capita higher than
Chicago and they're playing games with
election Integrity all of these local
democrat-run cases are being directed by
Washington we have a weaponized
Department of Justice a weaponized FBI
including of course
the break-in I used to go to networking
events and get stuck with people like
this and they go oh uh podcast and
YouTube huh uh you know in my day you
needed a license to say anything on the
radio and my dad had a good voice and
they say I got it but actually it was
really more my mom who taught me and you
know my mom liked to knit and when she
knit the thing about it was we would get
interference on the TV and I told her
mom you got to put that knitting away
because I can't hear a damn thing on
this television but TV used to go off
the air at 10 pm you know 24 7 TV is a
new thing I'm going
much stronger right Becca Mega you look
good you look good as a handsome guy
he's got a mega that hat is a hot seller
let me tell you
they're coming after me because I'm
fighting for you remember that they're
coming after me because I'm fighting for
you to every citizen who is appalled by
the radical left lawlessness and it's
unbelievable what's what they're doing
what they're doing is unbelievable it's
it's hard to believe even parental
rights I was saying the other days with
a group we're going to we're going to
stand up for parents who the hell ever
thought we were gonna have to stand up
for parents can you imagine you're up
here I guess we're politicians I never
felt like a politician but I'm saying we
will stand up for you parents and then I
say can you imagine we have to actually
say that Kim right even say it but this
election is your chance to make your
voice heard this is a big deal with you
that's nothing Biden had to defend
democracy in his speech yesterday and it
kind of say we kind of want that you
know
free country
you could take the five worst Presidents
in American history and put them
together
damage Joe Biden has done to our nation
in less than two short years here's a
clip does anyone want to see a little
clip on a nice expensive phone here it
is how would you say your mental focus
is
[Music]
what's focused
I said I think it's I I haven't look
let's get her ready to come back
I think it's a right for people that bad
and can't care
through an international pressure
said that America is a nation that can
be defined in a single world
Corn Pop was a bad dude and he ran a
bunch of bad boys wait wait wait all men
and women created by the goal you know
the you know the thing if you hold near
and dear to you that you uh
um like to be able to
anyway
but we went because this stuff makes a
lot of sense I've had more
investigations than Jesse James Billy
the could no more dropped by the Dropbox
is a selfie
cephahide we've endorsed JP right JD
Mandel Mexico and a rhino named Mitt
Romney Obama and the combat Infantry
virtue cycling truth essential fresh
vegetables then he went Donald Trump
killed Donald Trump take a look at the
oranges of the investigation advising
lawmakers Americans of all walks of life
do you care about law
oh clear sir
very much what
[Applause]
thank you
so
[Applause]
so it is sad and it's not really
anything that's funny because our world
is in a very dangerous place with
nuclear weapons and it's the first time
I've ever heard such talk about nuclear
you know the nuclear word was never a
word the n-word should be discussed and
now every day a certain country is
mentioning it and now another country as
you know North Korea we got along very
well that was supposed to be a big war
if I wasn't elected that would have been
a war he expected to have War
tremendous nuclear capability and Russia
mentioning it all the time now it would
have never happened but we could end up
in a third world war because of what's
going on and the stupidity of what's
being said
and uh it's a very serious problem it's
really is we have
somebody leading us that should not be
leading us it's a we could end up we
could end up in World War III and World
War III we'll blow everything away
because World War III has nuclear
weapons like nobody's ever seen and
other things and we can't let that
happen but we could very well end up in
World War III under my leadership we had
for the first time American Energy
Independence and even energy dominance
now Biden is begging and pleading with
we still do actually the numbers are
freely available and they're cutting it
how about this oil per barrel reaches an
all-time high in the history of our
world and he announces we're not going
to drill anymore no when it reaches that
you gotta drill we could have cut taxes
we could have made so much money Anwar
and Alaska which the first day they
ended took 60 years I got it done nobody
else could get it done I got it done and
they ended it bigger than Saudi Arabia
they say under my leadership we gave the
largest tax cuts and regular Cuts
regulation cuts that was a good American
history bigger than the Reagan Cuts I
stood up for Iowa ethnic I think I got
some credit for that
so you know we ran twice and we won your
state twice and nobody's done for the
farmers and even ethanol and all of the
things like we did I stood up more than
any president in history for Iowa
farmers and for Farmers all over farmers
and ranchers and manufacturers all over
the country passing usmca virtually
eliminating the unfair estate tax or
death tax on farms and Farmers virtually
identical to NAFTA better said the way
you can if you like your child I always
say if you don't like leave it to
charity
some of us have horrible children do you
have any horrible children any does
anybody have like a child where you
really are not going to leave your farm
any farmers
Trump's like I'm not huge on my kids so
it's possible some of y'all aren't
either
but I got rid of the inheritance you
know what would happen you love your
children you want to leave it and they
end up going bust because they can't pay
the estate tax well deeply spiritual as
you can tell um so it's great
very important they were losing they
were being right they were being
decimated that you know they'd leave
they loved their children they'd leave
it to their children then they get this
huge estate tax they have to mortgage it
then they end up losing it that's very
sad stories I got rid of it call it the
death tax and standing up to China with
massive tariffs taking in billions and
billions of dollars when no other
president took in literally 10 cents not
10 cents over decades and I gave
a portion of that to the farmers because
the farmers were treated very unfairly
by the Chinese right oh he got a big
check you got to check
I'll bet that guy got a big he's
standing up and giving me a high five
who you look at him and he looks very
prosperous
and you know how much money I took out
of China for just the farmers 20
and we just lost the feed remember that
American companies pay the tariffs
American companies pay the tariffs
something weird is going on with the
video here
but we are looking at it very very
strongly to be totally Frank let's see
this is kind of weird
uh is Newsmax even covering it and and
telling people
[Music]
wow Newsmax isn't covering it and the
feed just died huh
are we back those things but I was a
little different and then we secured a
deal that included the largest
agricultural
what is worth of our farm product and
all of you are still benefiting but I
think Eric they're not like they lived
up I used to check it every week are
they buying are they buying 50 billion
remember they wanted 15. they Farmers
wanted 15. and I said let's make it more
you know it is a billion and a half
people I said let's make it more because
I told my people make it 50. they said
50 and then the farmers came back they
said we have a problem I couldn't
believe they said this Kim they said we
have a problem we can't produce that
much I said you'll figure a way what's
funny is it's no more coherent without
the glitches bigger pieces of land and
bigger tractors okay and that's what
they did they went out Jeff and they
bought more land and bigger tractors and
it worked out great but now I understand
that China's not living up to the deal
because they don't respect the
administration to put it mildly well and
a Bad Thing could happen in China too
with Taiwan let's see what happens like
it wouldn't have happened with Ukraine
it wouldn't have happened with China but
let's see what happens because they're
circling it right now we ships all over
the place Biden and the radical left
Democrats have devastated the American
Farmer with crippling fuel costs
fertilizer shortages I mean the
fertilizer stuff I hear is just a mess
right
fertilizer we didn't have any fertilizer
shortage we didn't have diesel sir it's
a pile of manure sir another 21 days
left lots of luck after that
but it's only going to get worse under
the Trump Administration we had the
greatest economy in the history of the
world with no inflation and a man who
really helped me with that was a guy
named Chuck Grassley he really was
unbelievable he was unbelievable where
is it where is Chuck he's Chuck Grassley
he was
he was here unbelievable he look you
know I'm looking at it with that
beautiful green hat he looks like he's
like 40 years old you are unbelievable
you're unbelievable
right I'm going to introduce him in a
second but I had to say it he helped me
more than just about anybody he's
incredible he loves this stated he loves
the farmers and he loves ethanol I said
how good is it he said it doesn't matter
we want it
there's no games with Chuck
and he got it Biden and the democrat
congress created the worst inflation in
50 years 9.1 percent but it's much worse
and don't think you're buying a turkey
for Thanksgiving because they're not
available and If you get them you're
gonna have to pay three there's plenty
of turkeys I also don't know people who
buy them this early usually you just
order it you pick it up the week of
Thanksgiving I was just in the Whole
Foods it's stuffed to the gills with
turkeys putting our nuclear capability
and the creation of space force first
time in 79 years
which is a big deal too
they surrendered our strength and turned
Afghanistan into the greatest
humiliation our country has ever had and
now we have a war between Russia and
Ukraine with potentially hundreds of
thousands of people dying that would
never have happened if I were president
would never it was not even thinkable
number one the energy cost the price per
barrel was at forty dollars he can't
have a war he can't afford it at a
hundred dollars he can afford it the
election was rigged and stolen and now
our country is being Trump's
understanding of foreign policy and
economics is a little shaky second time
than I did the first getting Millions
more votes in 2020 that I got in 2016
and likewise getting more votes than any
sitting president in the history of our
country by far and now in order to make
our country successful and safe and
glorious
I will very very very probably do it
again okay
oh no
does Trump announce on Wednesday next
week what do people think let me know in
the chat
yeah
you know Mike did me on 60 Minutes
[Applause]
Ah that's nice well
get ready that's all I'm telling you
personally get ready
the radical Democrats are currently
trying to eliminate Iowa's first in the
nation status in presidential elections
I told you that remember four years ago
I said I'm not gonna let it happen not
going to let it why is Iowa first I
stopped it so much it's almost became a
full-time job they do want to take it
away from you then I can say but the
Iowa caucuses are cherished and it's a
it's really unclear it's good for
democracy for Iowa to just arbitrarily
be first years to come we're not moving
to Kim okay it's not happening
I've been saying that now for six years
and so far I've been very successful but
there are a lot of people that want to
move it you know that it's not going to
happen but before we talk about 2024 we
have to win a historic victory for
republicans in November 8th right here
in Iowa
you have the chance to re-elect one of
the strongest toughest and most
courageous members of the United States
Senate
and he is the one and only Chuck
Grassley Chuck
has devoted his entire life to serving
the people of Iowa and he does it
brilliantly and he's a tough guy and
he's respected by everybody that voice
all I remember when he was he was doing
like an inquisition on a guy named James
Comey remember that uh
and you know in his normal voice he said
did you leak it
and he was being nice he wasn't even
just a voice it's very powerful it's
like at this scary voice and Comey who
said did you link it
uh he's got huh yeah yes I did I said he
just said he leaked it
you're the only one could have gotten
him to say that right that was the
beginning of a real mess let me tell you
but while also visiting all 99 Iowa
counties every single year and he's done
it every single year
I was in the Oval Office with him once
and break the middle of a sentence I was
talking he said I have to leave sir I
said well I'm in the middle of this I'm
telling you about ethanol or something I
don't know what the hell I'm telling you
about he said no sir I have to leave I
haven't missed a vote how many years
Chuck
he said I haven't missed a vote in 27
years sir and I respect you a lot but
I'm I'm out of here
I said it's okay Chuck come back later
he didn't miss that vote did you no he
hadn't missed if I think of that in
terms pretty engaging story huh in terms
of just something very special I mean
who's like that but he hadn't missed it
and he went out and he voted and he also
very importantly he votes the right way
that's even more important as a farmer
himself Chuck is a fierce offender of
our Farmers he's critical and I mean he
is so critical in defending your
interest when the farm bills are written
oh he's brutal during Farm Bill time
and call you 30 times a day until he
gets it just perfect and he was
instrumental in passing the usmca a
giant win for American agriculture in
fact so good that Mexico and uh you know
that Canada especially because with
Trudeau they want to Mexico it's turned
out so good we got rid of NAFTA the
worst deal ever made worst trade deal
ever made but Chuck is also a loyal
defender of your second amendment and he
played a crucial role in confirming
nearly 300 federal judges to claim your
free Trump knife
wow given what's going on with right
wing inspired violence he's offering a
knife now
wow A Brave few who stand up to
Washington corruption this man is not
corruptable I will tell you there are
some in Washington that they are
but uh America needs this is a very
special man this is a uh really a get
your free Trump ice pick
but America needs Chuck Grassley in the
U.S Senate so Chuck is running against a
radical left Democrat named Mike Franken
who's an open borders extremist he's an
open border extremists who wants to see
drugs criminals illegal aliens pouring
into our country not too good I don't
think that's Iowa values is it meanwhile
Franken has vowed to massively raise
taxes across every income bracket and he
wants to defund the police I met all
those police back there I don't think
where's the sheriff with that beautiful
family I don't think the sheriff is
going to be too happy where is he this
guy's Central Casting I'm going to put
that I'm going to where is he
I'm gonna put him in a movie he's like
Central Casting his family is better
looking than he is too
I don't think the sheriff is endorsing
Franken
with his open with his open border
policy Sheriff but we uh we really have
he's running against a a guy that let's
put it this way he's weak on crime
terrible in the Second Amendment and
he's a big government liberal who will
sell out the state of Iowa to the
radical left that's what he's doing
that's why we have to elect Chuck
Grassley Chuck just come up for a second
Chuck come on up remember you have to
praise the cult leader and not speak for
too long when Trump calls you up
otherwise Trump gets very bored
[Applause]
come on over
[Applause]
well
Geisha after that commercial I can save
a lot of money on television
okay for first of all thank you for
coming to Iowa thank you very much for
coming out here
I I told these people about an hour ago
that we thank you for coming because
you want to get this vote out
so we can turn around the bad policies
of this Administration now that
this person president Trump has come to
Iowa
what we have to do to back up his
efforts coming here and he's going to
many many states to do exactly what he's
done here he's already done it in a lot
of States huh and and we we thank you
for caring about the 2022 election
because we got two years of ruining this
country and I laid out for these people
that are here tonight the good things
you did in your four years as president
of the United States but most
importantly you kept your word and right
he built a wall across the U.S Mexico
border he replaced Obamacare with
something beautiful he solved the
israeli-palestinian conflict he he kept
his word guys he really did yeah so to
make sure that this trip by President
Trump here to Iowa is worthwhile every
one of you as I told you an hour ago you
got to get your family and friends to go
vote if we want to make a big difference
and get a congress that'll turn things
around and stop these bad policies
thank you
there you go
thank you very much chuck I'm telling
you he's the young looking guy
thank you very much chuck great job too
this Tuesday you also have to get out
and vote for your incredible governor
and she is Kim Reynolds she's an
incredible person incredible right from
the beginning
right from the beginning we've been
together right
and by the way her husband's a real
outdoors guy between him and my son Don
they weren't hunting a whole group of
people with a wonderful previous
governor happens to be the father of
Eric
the Brent said family and it was so cold
and so miserable and they had a hundred
people were going to go hunting and Don
Juniors really good he's like a plus
five Hunter
but he's really good and I'll tell you
anybody know what that means what's a
plus five Hunter the people 98 people
came back within a half hour
and these two guys were gone for three
days
they came back when they were supposed
to come back but it wasn't supposed to
be 20 degrees below zero and when they
came back they didn't even know what the
problem was we we thought we lost them
both right
uh he's uh he's a great guy Kim but Kim
is a proud fifth generation Iowa who
will never stop fighting for the workers
and families of your great state she
loves your state as your Governor Kim
signed the back the blue act meaning she
likes the police in the law
strengthening protections for Iowa
police officers and making rioting in
Iowa a criminal felony that's good a
couple of other places how about
Portland would you like to do that maybe
in Portland
you know there's nothing happens to
those people right nothing happens they
should do that in certain places that's
pretty good I don't you don't have much
of a problem with it but you won't now
anyway just in case you won't now
Crystal she got income taxes across the
board to a flat and fair rate eliminated
taxes on retirement income completely
and was recently ranked number one
governor in the nation for fiscal
responsibility wow
that's pretty good
I think that's the only thing you have
to have if you have that Kim you know
what if you have that I think that's the
end of that election
number one in the nation Kim is a
tireless Fighter for Iowa Farmers I can
tell you that because she also lots of
phone calls when there's a problem she
also fought to get Iowa students back in
school she protected your undersea
Second Amendment and Kim will continue
to stand strong against overreaches of
Biden and the extreme left so I'd like
to have Kim to come on up and you're a
very special person great Governor here
we go
this should be interesting
people were starting to come I want to
say what uh Echo what Senator Grassley
said he said thank you so much for being
here and I just want to thank you for
being a president who fought for America
who fought for Americans who believes in
this country and putting America first I
want to thank you for being a president
who fought for Iowa for Iowa families
Iowa Farmers Iowa's small businesses it
is such a stark contrast to what we see
from the Biden Administration and
Democrats who are dismantling this
country piece by piece and who want to
fundamentally change who we are as a
country well Iowans and Americans are
fed up and we're going to take our
country back and it starts on November
8th thank you God bless you
President John will J Trump
[Applause]
oh man wow
that was good
so everybody get out and vote for Kim
and vote for Chuck these are two
incredible people and I know they're
gonna have a big Tuesday we really know
that anyway but yeah I wanted to come up
here just in case we don't want to take
any chances we're also joined tonight by
the first gentleman who I uh already
spoke about Kevin Kevin Reynolds thank
you very much that's so great Kevin Kim
stand up Kevin do you please thank you
just stand his pillow there
and also the next Iowa Attorney General
and I'll tell you Brandon Byrd does
everybody know brother Birch is
incredible
and I want to let you know and this is
at the request of Kim and Chuck and
everybody here frankly and I was going
to do it anyway but I got to get it done
quickly she has my complete and total
endorsement okay Brenna she's fantastic
all right she's fantastic all right
now that's going to get you over the top
you know we have a
you're gonna be perfect okay great job
everybody uh loves you brother so they
all said could you do that I said yeah
we did a little research and develop
into it I said she's fantastic so I
think you're going to do great good luck
okay complete and total endorsement for
Brenna
a woman who's very shy very quiet
doesn't like to stir things up
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
where is Marjorie
she is so popular too
former acting attorney general and a
friend of mine Matt Whitaker Matt
and what a good guy he is
a man who's been with me
for a long time I'll tell you he's been
incredible one of the truly talented
people in his profession and if
everything works out I told him tonight
come on to the White House everything
works out because he is talented GOP
chairman Jeff Kaufman Jeff
he's been our friend for a long time
Jeff you've done a great job really
great job South Dakota chair
Dan Lederman Dan thank you Dan
and how is how is Christy doing good
all right you let her know well whatever
I can do okay she's terrific Woodbury
County Sheriff Chad Sheehan okay that's
the guy
listen to the people he's naming my God
uh a very special person assistant to
the traveling secretary bran said he uh
he's our manager out here and he just
calls he just he just says like I said
how are we doing he said they love you
out here sir they love you is there
anything I have to do no sir you've done
enough you don't have to do that's the
kind of stuff other people that say Sir
yeah you have to be out here immediately
do I have to Sir says you're doing great
here well you know we take care of you
we take care of business right like Kim
like Chuck we take care of business
and also the single greatest purchaser
in the history of advertising Mike
Lindell
[Applause]
or countries have now been taken by the
machines yeah if he could purchase my
ads I'd get 10 times more for the buck
there's no human being that's ever had
more ads than Mike I don't know how the
hell he does it but I'm gonna figure it
out someday Mike but he's a great guy
too and he's a great Patriot when
Republicans take back Congress next week
we'll be fighting for the people of Iowa
and we will win for the people of Iowa
one of the first things we must do is
stand up for parents rights we will get
critical races is he gonna do teach
transgender
we're gonna get it out of our military
we're gonna get it out of every part of
our federal government that I had it out
of our federal government then they came
along and the first day the first day
they put it back no teacher should ever
be able to change
every parent in America must be
empowered to opt out a forced
indoctrination in the classroom and send
their child to the public private
Charter religious or Home School charter
of their choice we will also
and they hate when I say this because by
even my people but I don't listen to My
People Too Much you probably saw that
for four years when they're no good I
say look do me a favor let's get the
hell out of here I got to get somebody
else
we don't have time to mess around but
they don't like it when I say it because
it's not politically correct we want to
keep men out of women's sports is that
okay
not politically cool
I still haven't figured out why it's not
politically correct right you know
I'll tell you those records are being
broken at levels swimming records that
have held for 20 years of being broken
by 25 38 42 seconds it's crazy no
teachers should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children without
parental consent there it is
can you imagine can you imagine we even
have to say this stuff anybody know what
that means does anybody have any idea
what that means please
another one of our highest priorities
under a republican Congress will be to
stop left-wing censorship and to restore
free speech in America
by the way where's the man he's a state
senator and he's the first one where the
hell are first will you come here just
come here oh no
this guy was with me in 2015 and he was
the only one with me from the state
I had a couple of guys that flaked out
on me but he was would you just say
hello to this group
I am
overwhelmed look at this guy
thank you president Trump I'm ready to
get on board and make this country great
again God bless you I love you foreign
[Music]
great state center but we were like a
lonely twosome
we were lonely but it didn't take long I
must say because we sort of ran the
table after that but he was really good
I just wanted to mention I saw him up
today I said you you look so familiar
you look so great handsome guy per
million I'm the guy I said you you're
that guy
so anyway take good care of him
everybody go out and sign up now also
for truth social it's a it's a hot site
better than did you see last week it was
number one Tick Tock was number two
Twitter was number five
they had something called WhatsApp what
the hell is that you say what's that
what is WhatsApp do you know WhatsApp I
don't know but I hear it's hot but it's
hot it's so hot it was in the fourth
place
and Trump think of it that's brilliant
you take truth social was number one and
I hear Tick Tock is trillions of dollars
at everything else they must be going
crazy and you know why because all these
people have joined it's incredible
actually what's happened and everywhere
the Republican party has a chance we
must pass critical election Integrity
reforms including Universal voter ID
that's not too hard
can you imagine they don't want voter ID
and they don't want citizenship ID in
other words if you come from a foreign
Planet it's fine to vote because it's
very now there's only one reason they
don't want these things because they
want to cheat otherwise who wouldn't
want
in fact I think it was I saw Paul 82
percent of the Democrats wanted the
regular Democrats right probably 100 of
the regular ones but they don't want
voter ID no more fake drop boxes no
private money pouring into local
election offices But ultimately I hope
you can do it here
we need same-day voting with only paper
ballots you're going to have a hundred
percent so simple you'll save a lot of
money Kim
and you can do uh a mail-in ballot for
people that are very sick legitimately
sick people that are legitimately sick
Trump voted by mail they cheated so much
using the ballot system with the covid
they use covet in the ballots but same
day voting voter ID think of it you know
in the old days you'd have a day now you
vote over 50 days they put these boxes
here and they put ballots there and they
have wheelbarrows and they're nobody
knows what the hell's going on you see
the doors opening and the cheating is
incredible same day voting all paper
ballots you're Trump voted early and by
mail save a lot of money and voter voter
ID everybody you know the Democrats when
they had their convention they had a
thing that they carried it was like this
big
and it was occurred it had their
fingerprints it had their fingers their
face that had side views their fingers
it had views of their ass
they had everything
they had everything
people so they had that for their
Democrat National Convention they had
more views of their body and everything
else
but they don't want voter ID when you
come to vote you know because they want
to cheat so I you should do that you
know that would be the most popular
thing you could do yeah be the most
popular thing you could do and you'll
save money you don't have to go with all
this crap that they sell you going up
here going there around the Moon
which is five days away from the most
important midterm election in American
history and we need a landslide so big
that the radical left cannot rig it or
steal it the bigger it is
far better than voting by mail-in ballot
is voting in
and on Election Day I'm hearing that
from so many people that voting on
Election Day is better now if you can't
do it you're sending your ballot but
voting on Election Day you're going to
swamp them it's much harder for them to
cheat is it just me or is the crowd
looking unsettled and sort of like it's
cleared out or moved around all of a
sudden it's like different on the stage
behind them I don't know I'm right gee
we can't find that stack of ballots you
know
whatever you do they'll get out and vote
and if you care about election Integrity
volunteers and election worker poll
Watcher or poll Challenger we need you
this is the year we're going to take
back the house we're going to take back
the Senate we're going to take back
America and in 2024 most importantly we
are going to take back our magnificent
White House right right we're going to
take it back now do the Q a music
we're gonna take it back
[Applause]
should have never left you know that we
know that everybody knows that together
we will fight for more jobs for Iowa
families fair trade for Iowa workers and
more Iowa factories forging more
products stamped with Uncle Sam help me
with this one that beautiful phrase made
in the USA Uncle Sam
we will shut down Biden's border
disaster reinstitute our strong remain
in Mexico I had that oh that was such a
great thing they had to remain in Mexico
Biden said no we don't want that and
actually a judge actually overruled them
it was so good you think that was easy
to get tell the Mexican Government we
want them to remain in your country you
think that was easy not easy I said if
you don't do that I'm going to put
tariffs on everything that you said to
us well we'd love to do it actually sir
who told you
strengthen the Patriots of ice border
patrol and we will again end Catch and
Release we will end chain migration
these are things you don't know but
they're bad just trust me Melania is in
the U.S due to chain migration I'm sorry
melania's parents are in the U.S due to
chain migration and legally
we will stop the
democrat-run cities we will give our
police the power they need and the
respect they deserve and we will not
take legal protection away from our
police they want to take away protection
of a policeman or woman has a problem
they want them to go out and get their
own lawyer no we're not doing that we're
going to protect them it's horrible
these things that they do we will
restore Law and Order In America we will
hold China accountable for unleashing
the virus upon the world
we will abolish all coveted mandates
commonly known as the China virus
mandates are locked are there any such
mandates and lockdowns going on anybody
know I don't know with an apology and
with back pay
we will defend our constitution we will
defend the Second Amendment and we will
proudly uphold the judeo-christian
values and principles of our Nations
founded
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and to always respect our Great
American flag
in conclusion our Maga movement make
America great again you understand that
in conclusion I didn't read the book but
this was the best book report I could
come up with by far the greatest
political movement in the history of our
country and the fake news never even
challenges it they don't challenge us no
there's nothing they can say if I say
anything that's slightly wrong they'll
challenge when I say make America great
again is the greatest political movement
in the history of our country they never
challenge it together we are standing up
against some of the most menacing forces
entrenched interests and vicious
opponents or people have ever seen
despite great outside dangers our
biggest threat Remains the sick Sinister
and evil people from within our country
I mean that too they are sick people
but no matter how big or powerful the
corrupt radical left Democrats that we
are fighting against constantly fighting
against a net they just don't stop
they you beat them and they start you
beat them again and they got something
else misinformation all over the place
but you must never forget this nation
does not belong to them this nation
belongs to you is it time for the cue
music now it belongs to you Jeff
this is your home this is your heritage
and our American Liberty is your
god-given right
this great state was founded by tough
Frontier men and strong pioneer women
who defied the dangers to carve out a
life and a home for their families they
tamed the Wilderness they braved the
elements they toiled and tilled the soil
they worked the fields they built the
factories they fought the battles they
poured out their Blood Sweat and Tears
to make this country into the greatest
nation in the history of the world
[Music]
there it is
[Applause]
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
but now we are a nation in Decline
we are a failing Nation
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation in 50 years
do you think no one comes to him and
sort of says maybe we should cut this
part out or do you think the people
around him also think it's good likewise
we are a nation that has the highest
energy costs in the history
of this planet we are no longer energy
independent or energy dominant
as we were just two short years ago
we are a nation that is begging
Venezuela Saudi Arabia and many others
for oil please please please help us Joe
Biden says yet we have more liquid gold
right under our feet than any other
country we are a nation that is consumed
by the radical left's green do deal
yet everyone knows that the green New
Deal will lead to our destruction
we are a nation whose leaders are
demanding all electric cars even though
they can't go far costs too much and
whose batteries are produced in China
with materials only available in China
when an unlimited amount of gasoline is
available
inexpensively in the United States but
it is not available in China we are a
nation that ended oil exploration and
production in the United States just as
the price of oil reached an all-time
high what other country would do such a
thing we are a nation that surrendered
in Afghanistan leaving behind dead
soldiers American citizens and 85
billion dollars worth of the finest
military equipment in the world
we are a nation that allowed Russia to
devastate a country Ukraine
killing hundreds of thousands of people
and it will only get worse
it would never have happened with me as
your commander-in-chief and for four
straight years it didn't happen and
China with Taiwan is next
not super inspirational I have to tell
you law enforcement against opposing
political parties like never before
we've got a Federal Bureau of
Investigation that won't allow bad
election-changing facts to be presented
to the public and which offers one
million dollars to a writer of fiction
about Donald Trump to lie and say it was
fact and pays a man two hundred thousand
dollars to get Trump
where Hunter Biden's laptop from hell
was Russian disinformation and the FBI
knew it wasn't and the Department of
Justice that refuses to investigate
egregious acts of voting irregularities
and fraud
and we have a man who is the worst
president in the history of our country
who is cognitively impaired in no
condition to lead and is now casually
talking about nuclear war with Russia
which would be World War III and far
more devastating than you know what's
funny Trump's been using the exact same
speech for like six weeks or eight weeks
now and the entire Biden Russia I think
he just it's it's months old Biden
hasn't mentioned that in so long fake
news is all you get and they are truly
the end it was also out of context
obviously We're a nation where free
speech is no longer
[Music]
or people died of covet in 2021 then in
2020 we are a nation that is allowing
Iran to build a massive nuclear weapon
and China to use the trillions of
dollars it has taken from us to build a
military to rival our own and just two
years ago we had Iran China Russia and
North Korea in check career they weren't
going to do a thing against us and
everyone knows us they had great respect
for the United States and perhaps most
importantly could the crowd be any more
bored longer respected or listened to
around the world we are a nation that in
many ways has become a joke
and we are a nation that is hostile to
Liberty freedom and faith we are a
nation whose economy is collapsing into
a cesspool of ruin
whose supply chain is broken whose doors
are not stocked and whose deliveries are
not coming whose educational system is
ranked at the bottom of every single how
could anyone think that this is a good
idea large packs of sadistic criminals
and thieves are allowed to go into
stores and openly Rob them
beat up their workers kill their
customers and leave with arm loads of
goods but with no retribution with the
authority of our great police has been
taken where their families and pensions
have been threatened and their lives
would be destroyed for the mere mention
of the words law enforcement
we are a nation where Fentanyl and all
other forms of illegal drugs are easier
to get than formula for our beautiful
little babies a nation once revered for
its magnificent airports which are now
dirty and a crowded mess you sit and
wait for hours and then you're notified
that the plane won't leave and they have
no idea when it will where ticket prices
have tripled they don't have the pilots
to fly the planes they don't have the
qualified air traffic controllers and
they just don't know what they're doing
we are a nation that has lost its
confidence willpower and strength we are
a nation that has lost its way but we
are not going to allow this horror to
continue two years ago we were a great
nation and we will soon be isn't this
just way too long even for this crowd
like even his own sycophants who are
willing to stand around for hours
waiting for him are bored by this
nonsense
who broke save our country we will stand
up to the radical left Democrats and the
dangerous and unpatriatic rhinos and we
will fight for America like no one has
ever ever ever
fought before
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no Summit we cannot reach there
is no challenge we cannot meet there is
no Victory we cannot have we will not
Bend we will not break we will not yield
we will never give in we will never give
up we will never ever back down as long
as we are confident United and loyal to
the cause the tyrants we are fighting do
not stand even a chance because we are
Americans and Americans kneel to God and
to God Alone
[Music]
foreign
majority is back and stronger than ever
before
together has only just begun and it is
time to start talking about greatness
for our country again we are one
movement one people one family and one
glorious nation under God so with the
help of everyone here today
and citizens all across our land such
great citizens such great people we will
make America powerful again
we will make America wealthy again we
will make America strong again we will
make America proud again we will make
America safe again and we will make
America great again God bless you and
God bless America thank you very much
thank you everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
so another completely depraved but so
boring and low energy speech from Donald
Trump even the people there barely seem
to like it just completely off his
rocker but remember without the
followers he's just a guy talking to no
one
he has followers he has followers and
that should scare us the most that was
about an hour
20 a relatively shorter speech from
Trump compared to some of the ones that
he has done recently so here's the plan
for the next few days folks we are we
are almost 24 7 leading up to the
election on Tuesday night for which I
will of course be live okay we have the
Bernie rally coming up this weekend we
have the Obama fetterman rally coming up
this weekend we have other Trump rallies
coming up this weekend don't miss any of
it folks it's free if you're watching on
YouTube hit the Subscribe button folks
it costs you nothing
3.2 million people who did not subscribe
watched our videos in October folks we
gotta consolidate these subscribers it's
free and we are streaming wall to wall
to wall I mentioned wall to wall to wall
because it's like a cube okay I'm
talking in three dimensions if you're
watching on Twitch
make sure you're following if you're
watching on Facebook make sure to like
we will be here with you we will be here
with you a thousand we didn't make it no
but a thousand is the goal by Tuesday
night and we made it
31.9 of the way in just one evening and
thanks to S Prez dumping in another 14
subscriptions it puts us at 3 35. we
will carry this over ladies and
gentlemen
we're going all the way
oh God
make sure you know where your polling
place is make sure that you were voting
on Tuesday
a lot is riding on it a lot is riding on
it and I want to make sure that is the
most important message you must vote
in order to use the tool that is free
you're given one vote you'd better damn
well use it a lot of people already
voted which is a fantastic thing we're
going to be back we have so much going
on and it's going to be extraordinary
and we will see everybody very very soon
I'm worried about my espresso machine
that could be your headline
it's not a joke I'm worried about my
Lane
or
um
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
the lawyers are lawyers the lawyers are
lawyers get rid of them
I'm trying for getting rid of the
machine
so you have you know the good Geeks and
they patch it up and they fix it and
they put up better protection virus
protection but here's what my attorney
said she said
um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through on
the way to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
that is she said no you're not giving my
phone I said arrest me I've done nothing
wrong he said no we're not gonna arrest
you I swear you can do anything you have
yet and you can do it you can do okay
um get rid of the machine I've tried
from getting rid of the machine I'm
worried about my pillow no no truth
that's the worst thing for you because
your cervical nerves in your neck I will
send you